ARE BEING TOLD, WE WILL GO THERE
LIVE WHEN IT HAPPENS.
ANOTHER FOX NEWS ALERT NOW.
HOUSE MINORITY LEADER KEVIN
McCARTHY AND A DOZEN OTHER
HOUSE REPUBLICANS ARE GOING TO
VISIT MIGRANT FACILITY IN TEXAS
AMID THE ESCALATING CRISIS AT
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
MEANWHILE, THE BAD AND WHITE
HOUSES DEPLOYING EMERGENCY
OFFICIALS FROM FEMA TO HELP WITH
THE SURGE OF UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS DESPITE THE PRESIDENT
DENYING THERE IS A CRISIS.
FEMA GOES WHERE THERE ARE
DISASTERS.
U.S. BORDER PATROL REPORTEDLY IS
HOLDING MORE THAN 4200 MIGRANT
CHILDREN IN SHORT-TERM
FACILITIES.
NEARLY 3,000 OF THEM HELD LONGER
THAN THE 72 HOURS LEGALLY
ALLOWED.
HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI IS
BLAMING FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP’S
POLICIES FOR THE SITUATION AND
ECHOING BIDEN AND CALLING IT A
CHALLENGE, NOT A CRISIS.
>> WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
INHERITED IS A BROKEN SYSTEM AT
THE BORDER AND THEY ARE WORKING
TO CORRECT THAT IN THE
CHILDREN’S INTEREST.
SO THIS, AGAIN, IS A TRANSITION
FROM WHAT WAS WRONG BEFORE TO
WHAT IS RIGHT.
>> Harris: HOWEVER, LOUISIANA
SENATOR BILL CASSIDY SAYS
PRESIDENT BIDEN’S SO-CALLED OPEN
BORDER POLICIES ARE TO BLAME FOR
THE UNPRECEDENTED LEVELS OF
MIGRANTS CROSSING OVER.
>> EMPIRICALLY IT IS ENTIRELY,
YOU CAN’T HELP BUT NOTICE THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION CHANGES AND
THERE IS A SURGE SO WHEN PEOPLE
THINK THEY CAN GET IN THEY BEGIN
SENDING THEIR UNACCOMPANIED
CHILD ON A TRAIN RIDE ACROSS
MEXICO WHERE SHE MAY BE
KIDNAPPED AND TRAFFIC ON THE
HOPE THAT THEY ARE GOING TO BE A
WAY THROUGH BORDER.
THIS POLICY IS LEADING TO THIS
SURGE, THAT IS UNMISTAKABLE.
>> Harris: YOU’RE WATCHING
"OUTNUMBERED," I’M
HARRIS FAULKNER.
HERE TODAY, EMILY COMPAGNO,
KENNEDY, FORMER GOVERNOR OF
NEW MEXICO SUSANA MARTINEZ AND
IN THE VIRTUAL CENTER SEE TODAY,
LARRY ELDER, SYNDICATED RADIO
HOST AND EXECUTIVE PRODUCER OF
THE DOCUMENTARY "UNCLE TOM,"
ALSO AN AUTHOR AND ATTORNEY.
LARRY, I WILL START WITH YOU, WE
REALLY HAVE TAKEN THIS UP A PEG
NOW IN TERMS OF HOW THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS RESPONDING,
FEMA GOES IN FOR HURRICANES,
TORNADOES, FEMA GOING TO THE
BORDER WHERE SOME FACILITIES ARE
AT 700% OR ABOVE CAPACITY FOR
LITTLE ONES BEING HELD AND YOU
SAY WHAT?
>> Larry: WELL, DOESN’T THE
WORD FEMA, DOESN’T THE ACRONYM
"FEMA" HAVE THE WORD EMERGENCY
AND IT?
EVEN THOUGH THE THE AND
ADMINISTRATION IS CALLING IT A
CHALLENGE, NOT A CRISIS.
JOE BIDEN SENT SIGNALS TO PEOPLE
IN CENTRAL AMERICA THAT THERE’S
A NEW SHERIFF IN TOWN,
EVERYTHING’S GOING TO BE
DIFFERENT, THERE WAS EVEN A
MIGRANT INTERVIEW NOT LONG AGO
AND HE SAID THAT JOE BIDEN HAS
GIVEN US, GET IN WITHIN 100 DAYS
AND HE WILL ALLOW US IN, IT
DOESN’T TAKE A ROCKET SCIENTIST
TO BELIEVE THAT IF YOU SEND
PEOPLE TO THE BORDER THAT’S
GOING TO BE POROUS, THEY’RE
GOING TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF IT
AND THAT’S EXACTLY WHAT’S GOING
ON RIGHT NOW.
>> Harris: GOVERNOR MARTINEZ,
NEW MEXICO, I’M CURIOUS TO GET
YOUR TAKE ON HOW THE
ADMINISTRATION IS RESPONDING
WHERE THERE’S SO MANY CHILDREN
NOW, I DON’T KNOW IF YOU CAUGHT
IT LAST HOUR, DOWN AT THE BORDER
BORDER, THAT THERE ARE SO MANY
CHILDREN, SOME OF THEM TESTING
POSITIVE FOR COVID-19 IN CRAMPED
CONDITIONS AS WE RELAX THINGS TO
LET MORE PEOPLE IN AND WE CAN
HANDLE IT ALL.
>> Governor Martinez: THEY ARE
CRAMPED INTO THESE LITTLE
CONTAINERS BUT THEY ARE NOT
ALLOWING ANYONE, ANY OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO SEE EXACTLY
THE CONDITIONS IN WHICH THEY ARE
BEING HELD.
I THINK THERE SHOULD BE THE
VISION OF WHAT EXACTLY IS
HAPPENING AND NOT JUST NUMBERS
AND BEING TOLD THAT THEY ARE
CRAMMED IN.
WE HAVE THESE KIDDOS, 4200 OF
COME THROUGH, 3,000 ARE BEING
HELD BEYOND THE 72 HOURS THAT IS
PERMISSIBLE.
BIDEN CLEARLY GAVE PERMISSION
FOR THEM TO COME TO THE BORDER,
HE SAID THAT, HE MADE IT CLEAR
AND THEN IT’S FOLLOWED UP BY
PEOPLE IN THOSE COUNTRIES
SAYING, HEY, PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS
SAID WELCOME, COME, COME ONE,
COME ALL AND IT INCLUDES THESE
UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN.
I’LL TELL YOU, IF A CHILD IS
LEFT BEHIND, CAN’T KEEP UP
WALKING, THEY ARE LEFT BEHIND,
THAT’S INHUMANE.
THEY ARE NOT GETTING PAID TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN THEIR TRAVEL, THEY
ARE GETTING PAID TO BE TAKEN ON
THAT ROUTE BUT NOT TO BE
SUCCESSFUL.
>> Harris: YOU TOOK IT TO A
VISCERAL LEVEL RIGHT THERE, YOU
DID.
YOU PUNCHED, I THINK, EVERYBODY
MADE IN THE HEART.
GOVERNOR, WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT A
CHILD THAT’S LEFT BEHIND IF YOU
CAN’T KEEP UP IT MAKES ME WANT
TO CRY.
KENNEDY, WHY IS THE PRESIDENT
DOING THIS?
>> Emily: THE PRESIDENT IS
DOING THIS...
I HONESTLY DON’T KNOW, I GUESS
IT’S TO APPEASE PART OF HIS
FACE.
BUT APPARENTLY THAT BASE DOESN’T
LIKE COMMON SENSE OR A POLICY
AND I WANT TO GO BACK FOR
SOMETHING NANCY PELOSI SAID, THE
HOUSE SPEAKER SAID THIS IS A
TRANSITION TO WHAT IS RIGHT,
THIS IS VERY WRONG AND THIS
SHOULDN’T BE PART OF A
TRANSITION AND COMING YOU KNOW,
THEY ARE SITTING THERE PARSING
WORDS AND TRYING TO FIGURE OUT,
CAN WE CALL IT A CHALLENGE, DO
WE CALL IT AN ISSUE?
WE CAN’T CALL IT A CRISIS BUT
WHAT THEY ARE NOT THINKING ABOUT
IS AS THE GOVERNOR POINTED OUT,
THESE CHILDREN WHO ARE MAKING
THIS VERY, VERY DANGEROUS
JOURNEY, HOW MANY OF US COULD
TRULY MAKE THAT JOURNEY?
WE DON’T KNOW WHAT IT INVOLVES
AND THERE IS NO WAY OF COUNTING
HOW MANY CHILDREN STARTED AND
HOW MANY CHILDREN MAKE IT AND
ONCE THEY GET THERE THEY ARE
SLEEPING ON FLOORS, THEY DON’T
SEE SUNLIGHT, MANY SAID THEY
HAVEN’T SLEPT...
SORRY, SHOWERED IN SEVEN DAYS.
THAT IS AN ELLIPSE THAT IS
INHUMANE, THAT IS BEYOND A
CRISIS AND IF THIS IS THE
TRANSITION, GOD, I HATE TO SEE
WHERE WE LAND BECAUSE IT’S ONLY
GETTING WORSE AND WORSE AND
WORSE.
>> Harris: LOOK, WHEN YOU HEAR
NANCY PELOSI AND OTHERS SAY THAT
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT BIDEN
INHERITED FROM TRUMP, THEY HAVE
SEEN FIGHTS ACROSS PRESIDENCIES
FOR YEARS, THAT’S NOT NEWS BUT
HOW YOU RESPOND TO IT IS WHETHER
IT WORKS OR IT DOESN’T WORK AND
MY GOODNESS AT THIS RATE, WHAT
WILL THE NEXT PERSON INHERIT?
BECAUSE THEY’VE TAKEN THIS WAY
NORTH OF WHERE ANYBODY THOUGHT
WE’D BE.
I WANT TO GET TO REPRESENTATIVE
CHIP ROY, I MENTIONED HIM, HE’S
AT THE BORDER AND HE HAD THIS
RESPONSE LAST HOUR, WATCH.
>> THERE’S ONE THING THAT
CHANGED IN THE LAST COUPLE
MONTHS AND IT WAS THE INCOMING
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
WIDE OPEN BORDER POLICY BY THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, FAILURE TO
FINISH, LOOK, THEY ARE BASICALLY
TURNING DHS INTO A WELCOME MAT.
>> Harris: EMILY?
SPEECH IS SIMULTANEOUSLY
THINNING THE RESOURCES THAT ARE
GOING TO DHS SO THEY ARE
ESSENTIALLY HAMSTRINGING THEM AT
THE SAME TIME.
ANOTHER THING THAT STRUCK ME
ABOUT THAT INTERVIEW, HARRIS,
WAS AFTERWARD THE CONGRESSMAN
SAID, I’M GOING TO MEET WITH
BORDER PATROL, WE ARE GOING TO
GET MORE INFORMATION, MORE
STATISTICS, AND THEN WHAT?
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN HE TRANSFERS
THAT ADMINISTRATION INFORMATION
WHEN IT’S CLEARLY FALLING ON
DEAF EARS.
EQUALLY IT’S MORE DISTURBING
ABOUT THIS BRAND VERSUS MARATHON
APPROACHES THAT WE AS CITIZENS
ARE SUPPOSED TO BELIEVE THAT
THERE IS DECADES WORTH OF
SERVICE BRINGING A HEIGHTENED
PERSPECTIVE, BRINGING A
HEIGHTENED SKILL SET OF
DIPLOMACY, OF DEALING WITH THIS
AND MANAGING IT SO WE CAN HAVE
TRUST AND FAITH IN THEM BUT WHEN
WE HEAR FROM THEM THIS AGAIN,
SPRING VERSUS MARATHON APPROACH,
THIS IS A NEW ADMINISTRATION, WE
INHERITED THIS WITHOUT
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT THE ISSUES
PLAGUING THE SOUTH AMERICAN AND
CENTRAL AMERICAN COUNTRIES HAVE
LASTED DECADES AND THAT THOSE
LEADERS ARE SIMPLY SITTING BACK
AND WAITING OUT, ADMINISTRATIONS
WITH BORDER POLICIES FOR THE
NEXT ONES, THE CONTROL CARTELS
HAVE, INFLICTING THE TARGETED
PAIN ON THESE CHILDREN UNDER
MORE LAX AND INHUMANE RULES THAT
WE APPLY TO OUR FEDERAL
INCARCERATION SYSTEM.
THAT ABSOLUTELY SHOCKS THE
CONSCIOUS SO THEY DON’T WANT TO
TAKE THAT MESSAGING OF A CRISIS
TO HEART, THE REST OF US WILL.
>> Harris: LARRY, I WANT TO
HEAR FROM YOU ONE LAST TIME
BEFORE WE GO TO COMMERCIAL.
>>>> Larry: JEH JOHNSON, OBAMA’S
SECRETARY OF HOMELAND SECURITY
SAID ANY TIME THERE WERE MORE
THAN 1,000 APPREHENSIONS HE WAS
GOING TO HAVE A BAD DAY.
THIS IS WAY, WAY MORE THAN THAT
AND REMEMBER, BUT FOR THE FACT